hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
so we seem to have a whole bunch of
questions here that have come in to our
form or been asked in previous weeks and
not answered
let's see maybe we should jump into a
difficult one here from anony mouse i
guess
um
the question is so do we live in a
simulation or not
you know i have to say this is a
question which people have been asking
different forms for
many many centuries the question is
we experience things internally we
experience the fact that i'm looking at
a camera i can touch you know my
computer i can do all these kinds of
things there seems to be a real world
out there
but how do we know there's a real world
out there
why isn't it the case that maybe we're
just
you know our our mind is just in a
computer somewhere and everything was
we're experiencing is just aspects of
what's being fed into the program that
is running to make our mind so to speak
how do we know that there's an external
reality that is beyond what is just our
uh that is not just being sort of fed to
us
um in some virtual way
and i think one of the popular
uh sort of uh
thought ideas
of recent times is well the way that our
technology is developing
we are making you know great video games
we're talking about meta
we are talking about hanging out all the
time
in
this kind of virtual world and we're
talking about maybe having direct
connections between the virtual world
and our brain
and so on
how come and that that will be the
future of our own civilization and our
own technology development
well if that's the future
you know
maybe we're living in that future and
that future is simulating the past as in
the kinds of things that we experience
today
maybe in fact
really in some sense it's 3000 a.d or
something and we're all just in some
virtual environment which is simulating
uh you know 2022.
so the question is can we sort of unpack
that idea does that idea make any sense
uh
how does it how do we think through that
idea
and
okay so
i i sort of have a a
somewhat perhaps
fresh
thinking about this because we now think
that we understand how
to make a fundamental theory of physics
in the past one had always thought well
there's the physical reality of the
world and physical laws and gravity
operating on things and things dropping
and you know actual atoms and all this
kind of thing
and then
that's the physical world
and if we were sort of in a video game
we might have a software emulation of a
world but it's different from the
physical world and part of the point
there is well we don't know how the
physical world works
but what's happened as a result of our
physics project in the last couple of
years is we have a pretty good idea how
the physical world works kind of all the
way down
and what we realize is that the physical
world
is we think made and i'm not going to go
through the whole story here but in the
end for example space is made up of
these discrete atoms of space and this
giant network that represents how those
atoms of space are related and all the
things that we experience
in the world are the result or we can
think of them as being the result of
essentially running a program operating
on this giant network connecting the
atoms of space and so on
so
in a sense then when i say everything we
experience
can be thought of as being the result of
this sort of
uh abstract rule
running on this giant network that
represents atoms of space
they can be thought of as an interesting
term
okay so let's imagine that we say uh i
don't know
the earth is going around its orbit
going in its orbit around the sun
um
and it is following
uh it's
it's pulled into the sun by the inverse
square law of gravity and so on
and
we might ask the question
is the earth really moving according to
the inverse square law
or is that merely a representation of
how the earth is moving
and the earth is moving
in some way that we're not describing
that some sort of intrinsic physical way
that it's moving but it is merely
described by this mathematical construct
of the inverse square law
well in the way one starts thinking
about these things at the first level
what one has is merely a description
of how to think about how the world
works so we say we can represent how the
world works in terms of these abstract
atoms of space and rewritings of these
networks corresponding to abstract atoms
of space and so on but we're not
committing ourselves to that sort of
actually how it works but that's
actualized we're saying that that's a
representation of how it works but we're
not saying that's sort of intrinsically
how it actually works
now the in other words
um
what um uh i think the term that's been
used by philosophers it's something like
um how do you put the the fire into the
model so to speak how do you actually
how do you go from a mere description to
something which is actually the way it
works so to speak
okay so this gets kind of tricky
but uh and i think we have to go a
couple of different levels to understand
how this how this works
the thing that is
uh well first thing to say is
if we think we have a description of how
the whole universe works
these atoms of space these rules
they're reconfiguring them et cetera et
cetera et cetera
one thing that's a little weird about
that model
is that we ourselves are part of that
model in other words whatever is going
on in our brains
and that is producing our minds and so
on it too
is represented by atoms of space and
rewrites of atoms of space and so on and
so we're in this slightly odd situation
where
the observer of what's going on is
actually embedded within the system
itself and that puts us in a slightly
different situation from the more common
situation where we're saying there is
this thing out in the world we're making
a model of i don't know the flow of a
fluid or or a planet moving in orbit and
we are looking at it from the outside
we are observing it from the outside and
we're saying we can explain what's going
on by this or that rule
but we
are thinking through how those rules
work outside of the system itself
the situation with the whole universe is
quite different because we are part of
it
so we are kind of experiencing it from
the inside
so that's the first thing to realize is
that that
our sort of observation of the world is
from inside the system
now
i i want to comment on you know what we
really want to talk about is the
universal simulation so to speak
and
the
uh
by by which i mean what does one mean by
is the universe a simulation
what i think one tends to think one
means is
well
there's us on the inside experiencing
what we think we're experiencing in the
universe but there's an outside there's
the video game player on the outside the
kind of uh uh sort of the
the the super being
that's playing the video game and we're
merely preachers in the video game so to
speak
so what does it mean that there's sort
of a creature on the outside
it it means well the first question is
does the creature on the outside
uh just set the game in motion and then
it just runs itself
or is the creature on the outside every
so often pressing a key and saying you
know i want this person to do this or
that
you know it's funny because this is a
deeply sort of theological kind of
question
and it's kind of like this is all the
question of miracles so to speak
let's say the world runs according to
certain natural laws but every so often
you know in ancient greek times or
something it would be the olympians
would throw a thunderbolt at the
appropriate place
and uh would sort of change what's going
on even though there's sort of an
ordinary way the world operates there's
a certain density of from the outside
either the creature playing the video
game or the olympian or mount olympus is
throwing the thunderbolt and changing
what happens in the world in a way that
goes outside of the natural laws of the
world
so one has to first ask the question is
that what's going on are there lots of
miracles or is it the case that what
one's mostly dealing with is just
the player
started the video game they pressed go
and then the universe is after that just
running according to the rules defined
for the universe
well let's assume that
we insofar as we believe there are
natural laws and we believe that there
is not a high density of kind of quotes
miracles you know thunderbolts that come
from nowhere type thing
um
then we're really in a situation where
in a sense at very best
the simulator
the creature on the outside doing the
simulation is at most just saying i'm
selecting this game okay this is the you
know earth 2022 game or something and uh
you know humans whatever and then i
press go
and then that's it
and then everything else is just running
according to the natural laws of the
universe that we gradually managed to
uncover using science
so
okay so in that in that scenario
the thing that we're saying is there's
sort of a a thing on the outside
and one feature of the thing on the
outside is there's a choice
about
what universe do they run the earth 2022
game or do they run the you know torseti
3074 game
or do they run something else
or do they run a game with the universe
which is eight and a half dimensional um
you know in other words is there a
choice
in the creation of the world so to speak
on the part of the gamer on the outside
so that's one one question is what one
imagines if there is a simulator
one imagines a couple of things based on
our sort of everyday experience of sort
of the computational process
one thing is there's a choice in what
program to run that's one
feature the other feature is there's a
substrate on which the program is
running so in other words we're saying
that yes there is this way of describing
how the world works in terms of atoms of
space and this and that and the other
but if it is a simulation it is running
on something there is a computer there
is the the uber computer so to speak
which is being run by the uber creature
that is
the the thing on which our universe is
operating as a program
so there's this idea that there is some
substrate there is something that is
there's a chooser of the program and
then there is a thing that the program
is running on
okay well
so now the question is is that
uh so so that's that's a possible sort
of model of what's going on
okay
here's why i think that model doesn't
make any sense and this is this requires
us going even deeper into some kind of
rabbit hole to understand this
so what i said is there's this kind of
we we think we understand what the
universe is like kind of all the way
down
we know what the atoms of space are like
we know these rules that update the
items of space all that kind of thing
now in principle all that stuff could be
being emulated on a computer
or it could just or we could all the
atoms of space could be what sort of
really exists but
okay this is that we're going deep into
a rabbit hole here but let me let me
keep going for a moment
so
one of the big questions about sort of
finding a fundamental theory of physics
is this
let's say we have the rule that says how
the atoms of space are updated and
that's the rule that if you just keep
running it for a long enough time you'll
just get the whole universe
that would be a remarkable thing to have
one can hold in one's hand this rule and
maybe it's one line of wolfram language
code or something and one says just run
this rule for a huge amount of time and
you will get um precisely this um
this whole universe of ours
um and uh so then the thing that would
next come out is the question well how
come we got this particular universe
how come we got universe number 2711 or
something and we didn't get universe
number
30
214
who got that universe
why did we get this universe and
particularly if it's a simple universe
to where the rule is simple
uh even though the universe itself may
be very complicated you might start this
very simple rule how come we got this
particular simple rule it kind of seems
wrong
just like you say well where do we live
do we live at the center of the universe
people used to think that
we now know that we live in a pretty
random place
on a you know on a the outer part of a
pretty random galaxy
out of the you know 100 billion galaxies
in the universe there's nothing very
special about where we are in physical
space so it seems other than that for us
it's special because we're here
okay so in the space of all possible
rules it also seems implausible if
somebody tells you well we actually live
in this very special universe that was a
very you know specified by this very
simple rule and you know all those other
all those other universes that might be
have these much more complicated rules
and we're very special here that just
seems it doesn't seem like a plausible
claim
it seems very uh kind of haughty to
think that we would be in that very
special universe
i i worried about this for ages and i
realized the following thing
what if we're talking about these rules
for the universe and and how things run
now one thing i didn't kind of mention
is that
you specify rules for how this network
that is the connections between the
atoms of space you specify these rules
that say whenever there's a little piece
of network that looks like this you
should rewrite it into one that looks
like that you can rearrange it you re re
re-sort of thread things
in this kind of abstract representation
of all these connections it's kind of
like the friend network of the atoms of
space you're re reconfiguring the friend
network of the atoms of space according
to some particular rule and you're doing
that whenever you see a little piece of
friend network that looks like this
rewrite it to be one that looks like
that and you do that whenever you see it
now the thing that happens when you do
that
is that there might be many different
ways in which you can do that updating
and they might even overlap they might
even be do this one first then this one
and so on and so on and so on lots of
different possibilities
one of the great things with our model
of physics is the existence of those
many possibilities leads to many threads
of time
which precisely gives one quantum
mechanics and it gives one the
mathematical formulation of quantum
mechanics and so on it seems to be how
quantum mechanics really works
now one of the weird things about that
is there are these many different
possible histories for the universe and
we're saying that in some sense all of
those histories are realized but again
one of the bizarre things is that we
are embedded in this universe that has
many histories and where there are
branching histories emerging histories
and so on so in a sense and this is sort
of the story of quantum mechanics in our
models
is that
our minds our brains are also subject to
this merging of different branching and
merging of different threads of history
so it's kind of like how does this
branching brain perceive a branching
universe
or the weird things of quantum mechanics
are associated with that kind of
question
but okay so we've got this idea that
you've got this rule and maybe it's a
simple rule and you just apply it
wherever you can and you that leads to
this complicated history for the
universe many many threads of history we
kind of conflate those together
as kind of observers who think there are
definite things happening and so on and
so on and so on
okay so then you start thinking well
what if instead of running a particular
rule in all possible places you run all
possible rules in all possible places
let's so there's no there's no special
status that you give to rule 1374 or
whatever it is you're just saying run
all possible rules in all possible
places
okay that seems like an unbelievably
complicated messy thing to have and it
seems like how could you say anything
based on running all possible rules in
all possible places in all possible ways
for it for for as long as you want
well it turns out that that what you get
is not
just a total sort of anything can happen
kind of mess
and the reason is essentially so what
you're effectively doing you can think
of that as imagine that you have all
possible programs for computers
and you're starting them off with all
possible initial states and you're
running all these possible programs and
you're doing it for an infinite time you
get what you'll end up with is this big
entangled mess of different things that
happen but a very critical fact is that
two different programs might end up
producing the same output
and that very fact of the fact that two
different programs seem like they're on
different threads might actually merge
in what they do at a certain moment and
then those different programs might
diverge again but the point is that
there is it's not the case that all
these programs are just completely
independent of what they're doing
because different programs can end up
producing the same results and so if you
are sort of an observer of that universe
and even more so if you're embedded
within the universe as far as you you
are concerned these two programs they
just made the same thing and you can't
tell uh if you're just in that state you
can't tell which program it was that was
responsible for it okay well in this
kind of rabbit hole here
the next thing to realize is that we
are just as we are embedded if if we
believe that the universe is running
sort of all possible rules we are
embedded in this thing in which all
possible rules are being run
and so we
are then sort of our experience of the
universe
is based on also
being operating sort of having these
many different threads of history that
correspond to all these different
possible rules for the universe
and
but there's an important feature about
us and the way we think about things
which is that we think definite things
happen and
you know that's even though there are
many possible threads of history we
think definite things happen there are
many special features of us for example
we think we're persistent in time
we think that
uh it's the same me at this moment in
time and one second later
it's kind of weird that we think it's
the same me because if we went down and
we looked at how are we made out of
atoms of space
we would be made of different atoms of
space
at a quite different level you could say
that you know through the course of our
lives uh the various different atoms
that make up the cells in our bodies
gradually get turned over yet we don't
have any trouble saying it's still the
same me when i'm five years older
it's this idea that there's an essence
of us
that is kind of uh persistent through
time even though in that particular case
the material stuff of which we're made
changes
and
it's um
in a more extreme case an analogy one
can give you know imagine you've got
some water and you've got some vortex
that's moving through the water or
you've got some tornado that's moving
through the air even though the tornado
involves different atoms and different
molecules of air as it moves it's still
identifiably the same tornado
you know i just wrote a piece that i
think will get posted today
uh called on the concept of motion
uh which is one of these pieces that
that you would think somebody would have
written two thousand years ago and
people did write about these things two
thousand years ago but this question of
how you can have a thing that can move
and maintain its identity is actually a
non-trivial question in terms of these
kind of models of physics that involve
sort of atoms of space and things like
this it's not obvious that you can have
a thing that is like a tornado or
something or that in which the the the
sort of the underlying stuff in it
changes but the thing itself is
preserved and how that works for things
like electrons and so on in our models
of physics is a non-trivial question
but okay back to sort of our experience
of the universe
so in the end
what's happening is in this kind of i
call it the ruliad this this thing that
is this sort of entangled collection of
all possible computations
we
are kind of observers of that
we are experiencing kind of the universe
from some particular vantage point in
that roulette that is our the the state
of our mind or something corresponds to
some particular piece some particular
place
in that giant ruliad of all possible
computations and so on
so in a sense we can think of it as we
are at a particular place in rural space
just like we're at a particular place in
physical space and we experience the
universe from this planet going around
the star in this galaxy et cetera
territory that's where we experience the
universe from so similarly we're at a
particular place in rural space we are
experiencing the universe
with a particular
set of kind of interpretations of what
is going on in the universe we have a
particular we attribute particular rules
to what's happening and those correspond
to the the way that we
with our minds are parsing what happens
let me try and make this a little bit
more concrete
so
you know a good analogy is i don't know
something like a fluid like water
we interpret that as a thing you can
pour
you know you can pour it and this
stream of fluid comes out
underneath there are a bunch of
molecules in there and they're all bonds
bouncing around in complicated ways if
we were for example creatures that were
vastly smaller than we are in the size
of molecules and so on this whole oh you
pour the liquid and it comes out in a
you know in a stream and so on that's
not what we would say we would be
talking about individual molecules and
how they bounce around and things like
that
so in a sense there's a question of how
we parse
the the world around us we parse
something like the fluid in terms of you
know something that's flowing we can
pour it and things like that but that's
a feature of our way of our scale in the
universe the kinds of things we pay
attention to in that system and so it is
ultimately with the whole universe
that there are an infinite number of
ways that we could parse
the goings on inside this wooly ad
um but we are in effect
we exist at a certain place in rural
space and that is causing us to have
this particular way to porous
this whole ruling out of possibilities
okay why is this relevant to the whole
simulation question here's why
the ruliad
is all possible computations with all
possible initial conditions run for
infinite time and so on
the thing is there is only one ruliad
there is nothing there is no choice
about the ruliad the ruleyard is in a
sense all possible computations so we
could have different ways to represent
them in terms of one model turing
machines this kind of machine that kind
of machine all these different ways to
represent computations but in the end
what we've got in the rouliad is this
thing that is a purely formal object
that is kind of there's only one of
it's it contains all the different
possible axioms for mathematics it
contains all these different things
but there's only one of it we can
describe it in all sorts of different
ways we can say well we're describing it
in terms of you know the operation of
turing machines or the operation
of some other kind of computational
system whatever but in the end the
formal object there's only one of it
there's no choice about how it works
so
that means
that there isn't a sense there's nothing
to discuss
in terms of did they simulate tour did
the outer creature that's playing the
video game did they put in this
cartridge i don't know if video games
even have cartridges anymore but but um
did they put in sort of this game or
that game well there's no choice of
games the only game is the roulette and
the ruliad is a representation of kind
of what is the rule add is a is a
necessary formal kind of thing
just like if i define what two is and i
define what plus is define what equals
is and i'd find what four is two plus
two equals four
is not something where there's a lot of
wiggle room where i say well it might be
true or it might not be true given the
definition of terms two plus two equals
four is always
a thing
and
the same is true with this ruliad it's a
necessary formal object and there's only
one of it
so
then the so they're really two things
about the simulation
one thing is
that is there a choice in the simulation
is the simulator
the kind of uh
sort of the
the theological figure so to speak
that's that's uh choosing the universe
is that is their choice
and what we're saying here is when it
comes to the ruling ad there is no
choice the ruliad is the is the
representation of all formal things
and there's only one of it
okay so that
that's the first thing there's no choice
the second thing is what's the substrate
on which this is running
well it doesn't have a substrate because
it is merely a formal thing
it doesn't have a there's there's no
reason to talk about a substrate because
it is merely formal when you say two
plus two equals four you could say well
what is that running in it's not running
in anything you could say i could
implement it with stones or something
but that's just a taking of that formal
thing and turning it into something that
i'm representing in terms of stones but
there's a there's a formal thing that we
don't have to say where it's running at
all and the ruliad is such a formal
thing but the point is that in we are
embedded within that formal thing and
our experience is being derived from the
operation of that formal thing and
there's no need to sort of appeal to
some actualization substrate because
everything that goes on going all the
way from sort of what's the intrinsic
thing of the universe
to what is the thread of experience that
we have in the universe all of that can
exist within this kind of uh purely
formal system
so we don't have to kind of go outside
that so in a sense it no longer there's
no longer a reason to have a substrate
there there's no there's no substrate
that needs to exist
there is this formal thing which
necessarily exists and from which we
derive our experiences
okay so then the question is well so
does that mean the simulation argument
is just completely dead
well at some level it is but one
question is is there a choice about the
universe
is there something
that
is we said well there there's no choice
about the ruliad and there's no
sense in which there is an outer
preacher determining our universe but
the question is is there's still choice
and for example that's a question you
know is there still do we still have
agency in determining what our world is
like and so on do we or is it just
there's this clockwork thing and it's
just running and there is no
you know there's no sort of free will
everything is predetermined et cetera et
cetera
well at some level the ruliad is
predetermined it's it's just a thing
that exists
but the question of where we are in the
ruliad and how we choose to parse it
that in some sense is much more a matter
of
of a sort of in a some sense arbitrary
choice
in a sense our experience so how do we
experience the ruliad how do we
experience the universe
we experience the universe through for
example our senses you know we are
seeing things we're hearing things
they're things that are you know we
exist on a certain scale we are not
seeing individual molecules in the air
we are seeing things about you know the
flow of some water or something like
this
and the question is uh and so in a sense
our biology and our biological history
the history of evolution and so on is
determining how we experience the
universe it's determining how we parse
the universe in some sense it's
determining our position in rural space
and so can we move our position in the
real space well yes we can
imagine that we had completely different
senses imagine that in some future
technology we're able to understand
things that happen at the level of atoms
of space and we're able to do all these
different things then our experience of
the universe will be different and the
rules which will describe the the
natural laws which we'll use to describe
the universe will be different
and so in some sense we have changed our
universe at that point so in some
bizarre sense
rather than it being the case that from
the outside there is a con you know
there could be a controller of the
universe that's setting the universe the
way it is rather there is there's just
this ruliad that's this sort of all
possibilities but we inside this
are making the choice
about how we choose to explore and parse
and understand what's there so in some
sense we're the ones in control of sort
of how what our universe is like because
we're describing our universe right now
in terms of i don't know continuous
space and stars and black holes and
things like this we could be describing
our universe in terms of oh there's this
particular little quantum particle here
and there's this weird thing here that's
this connection between these two pieces
and so on we could be describing it in a
completely different way and in some
sense that would give us a different
experience of the universe
so in in some bizarre sense
rather than it being a conceivable thing
that there is a sort of outer simulator
of the universe
rather the universe is sort of a
necessary thing
but the features of of what the universe
is like the sort of the choice of game
in a sense is kind of all on us and it's
all on us having chosen to pass the
universe in the way we do which is based
on sort of our sensory experience and
it's based on kind of even our ideas
about science like the things that we
might say oh did you notice this or that
feature of the universe
well we notice it because we learned
some science or something and without
that science we never would have noticed
that feature of the universe and so we
would in a sense be parsing the universe
in a different way
so okay so that's the um
uh
uh gosh that was a bit of a long um um
uh yeah
just just to talk about some
uh
yeah this this whole question about sort
of
are we
merely our sensory experiences merely
being fed to us sort of by by a
conscious by by some by some purposeful
outside thing you know a movie like
matrix that was kind of the more or less
the idea i don't know i think it sort of
segued into things that were closer to
science of mine um about uh i didn't
quite understand some aspects of what
happened in the movie so um uh
in the later parts of the series so i
can't um i can't speak with authority
about what was intended there but um uh
in
i think
the um
again sort of trying to summarize this
since we now think we know what physics
is like all the way down
we can kind of say
is there room for a simulator there and
the answer is when we drop all the way
down to this ruliad
there just isn't the room for a
simulator because everything that we
drop down to is necessary
there is nothing there that is that is a
choice
um
and uh
it um
um
and so
so that's uh that's that's part of the
the story
and then this question of
so
uh that then the surprise kind of sting
in the tail
of well does that just mean we're stuck
with the universe as it is and there's
no choice in everything no actually it
isn't true because there is sort of our
choice in how we choose to experience
the universe
it is the the natural the laws of the
universe
ultimately at the level of the ruliad
are completely determined but there is
there are many things that are going on
there but we are choosing to pay
attention to only particular things and
those represent the universe as we
experience it as opposed to the universe
as some alien might experience it that
would have a different you know sensory
experience different science etcetera
etcetera
um
let's see
um
that's very weird
um
the uh okay let's see
um
okay william is asking boy you guys are
asking me to do serious philosophy and a
very um i mean let me be clear that
these questions about sort of external
experience and and so on
these are long-running deep
philosophical questions which we have a
different perspective on now primarily
as a result of the physics project and i
would have answered differently a couple
years ago i i didn't know any of these
things about the roulette and so on at
that time that's that's really new new
set of ideas
so william is asking about um
why do we perceive that we can make
choices what does it mean to make a
choice
so this is again a long-running
philosophical question about free will
versus determinism
the question is
are we
do we have a free will is our will free
of
uh can we make arbitrary choices
or is everything predetermined in the in
sort of the the behavior of the world
and of us
so
there's a there's a way to think about
this a little bit so
one of the things that can happen is
let's say there's a rule there's some
very precise rule that determines every
aspect of how we will operate or how
some system will operate
what one might have thought is if there
is a rule that determines how everything
works then it must be easy to predict
what the thing the person whatever will
do
and if you go back to you know science
fiction movies of the 1950s 1960s you
know they had robots in them and one
feature of the robots is they operate
quotes according to logic
and
it becomes they do very
sort of easy to predict things oh it's
operating according to logic so it will
do this and this and this
the general belief was that if there
were definite rules let's say simple
logical rules or just logical rules at
all that determine the behavior of the
robot it will be readily predictable
what the robot would do
well that turns out not to be correct
and that's something that came out of
particularly work i did in the 1980s
this idea that even though you might
know the rules by which a system
operates
when you actually run those rules you
can get in a sense irreducibly complex
behavior you can start things off you
know you have a little thing with a you
know one black cell and some array and
you run it for a while you get this
really complicated pattern the pattern
is completely determined by the rules
every time you run it you get the same
pattern it's the rules absolutely
determine what's going on it's kind of
like in sort of math you know you have
the digits of pi they're completely
determined by saying that the ratio of
the circumference to the diameter of the
circle when you generate them 3.14159
etc um that sequence of digits in many
respects seems completely random yet it
comes from a completely deterministic
definite rule
well so it is possible to have a
situation in which
when you run the rule it does these very
complicated things
and the only way you can find out what's
going to happen is essentially just to
run the rule
you might say
gosh i think i should be much smarter
than this little tiny you know
program the very simple program and so
on i should i as a human with a brain
and mathematics and
you know sophisticated computers and so
on i should always be able to jump ahead
and even though it took a billion steps
for this program to figure out what it
did after a billion steps
it's just wasting its time i should be
able to just do something where i can
jump ahead and 100 steps tell you what
you're going to do after a billion steps
turns out it doesn't work that way turns
out there's this phenomenon i call
computational irreducibility that means
you can't expect to jump ahead
now that phenomenon has sort of a it's a
bad feature in some sense for science
because it means you can know the
scientific rules by which something
operates but not be able to predict what
the thing will do
something that's important if you're
trying to sort of figure out i don't
know some epidemiological thing or
something and you say i know the rules i
can figure out what it's going to do
well not necessarily you might have to
run the rules through every step
basically to find out what will happen
so that's sort of the bad news about
computational irreducibility the good
news is if you're the the critter that
is running according to these rules
then you're sort of not wasting your
time
if we're running our lives put into
these rules
one might say if one could sort of jump
ahead don't lead your life the answer is
just going to be 42
and there's no nothing is achieved by
actually leading your life and going
through all those different steps of
this computation but computational
irreducibility tells you that sort of an
irreducible thing that's achieved by
doing that computation you can't know
the outcome except by doing the
computation and this relates very much
to the question of free will because
what it's basically saying is those
robots from the 1950s that obviously
didn't have free will they you know you
could poke them in this way in that way
and simple logic would tell you that
they will do this they obviously don't
have free will
but if they have computational
irreducibility you poke them and they
have this experience that experience and
you can't tell what they're gonna do
any more quickly effectively then their
brains can go through and figure out
what they're doing so there's no sense
in which sort of you can go from the
outside and say look that thing
it's all deterministic so to speak yes
the underlying rules might be
deterministic but you can't know what
those rules are going to have the thing
do except by essentially running those
rules or effectively just watching what
it does which will be the equivalent of
just running those rules
so i think
that
in a sense the idea of free will
is is a lot about this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility that
one is not free if it is readily
possible for someone from the outside to
predict what one will do
if the only way to know what one will do
is essentially to run oneself or to run
something equivalent to oneself then in
some sense that is something where one
is free of what is free of sort of
determinism in the sense one is one is
freed from sort of the ability to to
that once freed from sort of the obvious
determinism
where there will be an ability to sort
of jump ahead and see what happens
in a sense i think free will
can emerge from a deterministic system
with a sort of with this gap of
computational irreducibility between the
underlying determinism and the sort of
the actual behavior of the system
now you know you can unpack a lot of
things about these ideas about free will
for example if i do something terrible
um am i responsible for what i did or do
i just say no i was just following the
rules by which i was made and so i'm not
responsible for what i did
it's not really a good argument because
it is you intrinsically that follow the
those rules are you
and it is those rules that cause you to
do what you did so in some sense you are
quite responsible if if instead what you
say is well my rules are very simple
and uh and you know i just all i'm doing
is being buffeted by the outside world
you know
something
you know i don't know something happened
to me and so that caused me to do this
and it wasn't up to me i was
you could say in that case it wasn't up
to me it was something outside me
that i just uh sort of immediately
translated to doing the thing that i did
as opposed to the case of computational
irreducibility in me
where something might have happened from
the outside but there's this irreducible
computation that's happening purely in
me that caused me to do what i did and
so that second case where even though
it's deterministic underneath
the computations that have all happened
within me
gives me certain some sense
responsibility for what i did there's
intrinsic to me
uh sort of a something that's going on
that's causing that to happen so it's
like if you have a computer and some
future ai and it does something terrible
and you can say well it did it as a
result of the intrinsic things going on
in that ai you might say that's a bad ai
let's switch off that ai if one's
allowed to do that and and so on um
because it's a bad ai rather than the
other ai which just got you know a
programmer typed something in that
immediately caused it to do this bad
thing he said well that's not the fault
of that ai that's not the ai isn't
responsible it's merely from the outside
the ai itself is blameless it's not
something intrinsic to the ai
now you might ask in this um
model with the ruliad and sort of our
perception of the universe
how does the notion of sort of choice
work in that case and i have to admit i
have not thought this through completely
so it's um uh that's a case where
uh one of the things that's a bit
confusing about that
is it is a key part
of kind of the experience we have of the
universe that we believe that we have a
definite thread of experience
it is in other words we could
uh that is part of the defining
characteristic of how we parse the
universe
is this belief that we have a single
thread of experience
the belief that we are persistent in
time the belief it's the same us as a
few seconds ago
um that
in some sense is an arbitrary choice in
some sense that is merely our way of
describing the world
and i think
that one can kind of
see how that that merely our way of
describing the world thing turns into
something about kind of the way that we
make choices but i have to say that's uh
that's on my to-do list to untangle that
piece of philosophy and i don't think i
can do that in real time
um so a bit of a cl a bit of a
philosophical cliffhanger there i can't
can't tell you exactly how that works
and uh
so let's see a comment here from um
from craig uh every observer observes
the same dimensionless constants like
defined structure constant we don't have
any choice about that observation or is
one over 137 that lies on a sort of
observable manifold of julian okay
i think this just played into something
good here
so first first point to make
is
craig is mentioning this thing the fine
structure constant usually called alpha
its value is about 1 over 137 it's just
a number it doesn't have units it's not
in meters or seconds or anything like
that
um what is it
it is the thing
that in theory of quantum
electrodynamics
it is the thing that tells you
essentially the strength of electric
electromagnetic forces
it is when you have two electrons and
they are they have a force between them
it's the thing it's the sort of
dimensionless thing that determines the
size of that force
so it is we could imagine a world in
which that number is different we can
imagine a world in which electrons have
a different force of attraction between
them and and for example where the ratio
of the electric force to the
gravitational force of electrons is
different that that also depends on the
electron charge to mass ratio but but
the the intrinsic uh sort of uh strength
of the of the force due to gravity and
due to electromagnetism could be
different
okay so the question is is there a
different universe a different uh could
we be different kinds of observers where
we wouldn't
find the result
that this dimensionless force on the
electron is 137.
the answer is absolutely yes
and you don't even need all this
elaborate new kind of fundamental theory
of physics that even happens in
traditional particle physics
so let me try to explain this
so
the the buzz words for this i think of
the renormalization group and thing
called running coupling constants
and and here's how it goes
so
let's see
uh basically the point is
when you probe an electron with a
different energy you will find a
different effective value for its
electromagnetic coupling strength or its
its fine structure constant
roughly
the the question of of sort of how
what the force between these electrons
is
is affected by just how hard you kick it
if you're kicking it really hard you'll
see a different effective force and a
different coupling constant a different
value of alpha the thing that sort of
couples these electrons together
than you would if you kicked it with a
different different energy
okay
why does it work that way
um
in sort of traditional quantum field
theory the reason it works that way okay
so in the case of the uh
let me give well let me mention
something here it's an important effect
in particle physics it's called
asymptotic freedom and it relates to
quarks
so inside a proton
there are roughly three quarks
they're a bunch of extra for
counter-court pairs and things but
they're roughly three basic quarks
that are the inner structure of a proton
but you might notice that nobody
has uh said well we'll give you a you
know a bottle of porks
it's just there are protons there are
neutrons and so on but they're no
individual quarks that's because quarks
seem to be permanently confined inside
protons they have forces between them
that are associated with gluons that
basically
but that that pull these quarks together
with electrons with electromagnetic
forces if you pull them apart
uh if the further you pull them apart
the less force they'll be same with
gravity
the the
the further you put pull it apart the
less force it goes down like a one over
the the distance squared and so on with
corks
the so-called color force or the forces
so the gluons does not go down as you
pull them apart and so it actually gets
stronger as you pull the things further
apart it's like having a a string or a
spring between these quarks the further
you pull them apart the more force there
is to pull them back together again
so it turns out that a big thing was
discovered in 1973
is that if you kick these sporks really
hard then at least for a little while
they'll behave like there isn't much
force on them
they'll it'll be kind of that whole
spring thing doesn't sort of cut in for
a little while and so that meant that
there were it was possible to do
experiments where you could kick the
quark really hard and you could kind of
see the effect of the quark wobbling
around independent of the fact that it
was sort of locked in place by this by
this uh glue on forces and so on um and
so that is
that was sort of a big discovery because
when it's sort of locked in place it's
very hard to do the mathematics to work
out how things work but if you can get
it you can kick it hard enough that it
behaves as if it is only very weakly
coupled it can just move more or less
freely then it's kind of easy to work
out the mathematics and that was a very
important thing in the 1970s in fact i
was quite involved in in figuring out
some of how that works
but
in any case the um
uh
that is an example of where depending on
how hard you kick the quark
uh
and by kicking i mean you have a
particle accelerator and you have high
energy electrons and you're colliding
them into protons and so on and it's a
question of how how much energy there is
in that in that electron that's
colliding with the proton that's what i
mean by kicking it harder and so on
depending on that energy more accurately
the
transverse momentum but that you can
roughly consider it the energy um the uh
it's um
uh you will effectively see a different
effective value for this strong coupling
constant musical alpha sub s
same thing happens with electromagnetism
although the effect is much weaker
turns out an electromagnetism actually
that the harder you kind of kick the
electron the stronger the effective
forces will seem to be in the case of of
qcd of theory of quarks and gluons the
harder you kick it the weaker the force
will seem to be in the case of electrons
and electromagnetic forces the harder
you kick the stronger the force will
seem to be
um
roughly the reason for that is
that
around every charge
an electron electron might be a very
tiny thing we don't know how big it is
uh it's always been thought to be of
zero size in our model physics it's not
of zero size it has a size it's very
small compared to what we can see
experimentally but it does have a
non-zero size but that electron uh has a
sort of whole
coat of electron positron pairs and all
kinds of complicated quantum field
fluctuations and so on that exists for
any electron any electron is producing
all these effects of little quantum
vacuum fluctuations and all kinds of
things like this
well the harder you kick it the deeper
you see into that coat of other things
and that coat of other things tends to
shield the charge of the electron so the
effective sort of uh effective almost
electric charge of the electron is
effectively smaller um not
i'm alighting a whole bunch of technical
detail here but effectively the the
thing you see sort of the outer coating
of the electron at the scales we look at
it it seems like the electron has a has
this um electromagnetic sort of uh
effect that corresponds to one over 137
if you kick the electron really hard
it's not going to be one over 137
anymore it's going to be one over 100 or
it's going to end up being you know 0.1
or it's eventually it's going to get
actually really big if you if you can
drive down with higher energies if you
can see even closer to that very very
tiny inner electron inside its kind of
coat of other quantum effects
you'll see a larger coupling and
actually what happens what people think
happens is
right now there are forces like the
forces that hold nuclei together the qcd
forces the weak nuclear force
the um uh electromagnetism these are all
different
kinds of forces with very different
strengths
this idea of running coupling constant
means if you kick things very hard if
you kick them with an energy
corresponding to um
oh let's see it was uh a million times
the mass of a proton basically if you
convert a million masses of proton
immediately into energy you will get to
an energy at which
if you kick particles at that energy in
some sense
all of these coupling constants like the
fine structure constant alpha they'll
all appear to be the same value and
that's a that's a thing it's kind of a
that's sort of a thing that reveals the
fact that fundamentally these these um
uh underlying forces have something in
common to sort of unify um but it also
says that it depends on how you look at
it the fine structure constant even in
traditional physics
is its value of 1 over 137 is a
consequence of looking at it at very low
energies if we looked at it higher
energies if we were
in the translation that comes from the
uncertainty principle and the way
quantum mechanics works if we were
essentially very much smaller critters
we would be effectively operating at
higher energies and we would be sort of
seeing something where we no longer see
one over 137 you wouldn't say oh the
fine structure constant is 1 over 137
you would say the electromagnetic
coupling constant defined structure
constant is actually 1 over 100
if we were oh i don't know how big we'd
have to be let me think about that for a
second um
uh
can't do this in my head
um
i think if we were
a trillion trillion trillionth
of the size we are
we would conclude
about i'm sorry i'm not able to do this
it involves some logarithms and other
things which are far beyond what i can
what i can do an arithmetic in my head
um i think on that kind of scale size we
would be seeing an effective fine
structure constant of order one not of
order one over 137 so that's a sense in
which even
in this very traditional physics even
before we go to completely other ways to
to parse the universe um we see a
different value of the fine structure
constant
um
rbs is commenting what if the beautiful
images of stars and galaxies is really a
molecule in another universe
and time is very very slow in that
universe from our point of view yeah i
mean look the fact is i don't know if we
talk science fiction movies there's a
lovely sequence in men in black i think
that shows kind of the whole you know
the galaxy rolling up into a marble and
then sort of the whole universe is
actually uh put inside this this little
little marble or something and yes
there is a sense in which if we were
critters that were the size of a galaxy
we would have a completely different
experience of the universe we would have
different physical laws
uh for us you know the speed of light
will be really important
um you know most of the time well except
for our internet connectivity or
something it's we're starting sort of an
interesting thing isn't it that if you
look at sort of the experience of
us up until few decades ago
uh you know where does it matter what
the speed of light is it doesn't really
make you know we don't experience
anything
that cares about the speed of light
we're just oh it's fast you know speed
of light speed of sound maybe they only
differ by a factor of 10 or something
it's actually much bigger than that
right and it's actually um a factor of a
million
um and uh so
it um
um
uh it might be that um
uh you know
for a typical experience of the world we
might say oh i don't know light seems to
go fast maybe it's ten times the speed
of sound actually it's a million times
the speed of sound where does that
matter
in the past with the technology that we
had in the past it really didn't matter
much
there were you know indirectly there
were things about you know the operation
of a microwave oven and how big the
thing had to be and all that kind of
stuff to get a certain frequency based
on sizes of water molecules on you could
you could deduce how big the speed of
light had to be and why it matters to
sort of consumer appliances and things
but it's an indirect kind of thing now
with the internet
and the fact that we've got uh sort of
signals going through well often fiber
optic cables where they go at um
about two-thirds of the speed of light
typically
um the uh through glass light doesn't go
quite as fast as it does in a vacuum um
and and fibrotic cables are basically
glass
uh the um
uh it we're starting to have more
experience the speed of light because
it's kind of like oh we're pinging this
website that's on the other side of the
earth
um you know we have more direct
experience of oh it took
you know a tenth of a second to ping
that website on the other side of the
earth
um so we're starting our sensory
experience is starting to include things
that affect the speed of light that are
affected by the speed of light
if we were intrinsically if our brains
were vastly extended in the size of
planets or something like this
we would always we would have known
about the speed of light forever because
it would have been a critical thing in
the way that we would operate in the
world
and so yes it is certainly the case that
one could you know one's description of
the world depends on the way that on
things like the size one's at and you
know for example for us it's a big deal
that our brain is really slow compared
to the speed of light
in other words we look around us you
know i'm looking out of a window here
and i can see maybe uh
oh i don't know
50 meters away and um but the time it
takes light to come from 50 meters away
to my eye is absolutely tiny compared to
the time it takes the neurons in my
brain to register that particular uh
visual scene so for me the light has
arrived instantaneously i can describe
everything that i'm seeing is happening
at the same time even though something
i'm seeing you know might be 10
centimeters away and something might be
50 meters away it's still uh those
things seem like they are the the light
coming from them seems like it's
reaching me simultaneously so to speak
um because my brain is processing things
really slowly compared to the speed of
light uh if i was uh sort of very
different in size
that would be and i was routinely
looking to the other side of the earth
for example
it would be something and it mattered
that things were coming back from the
other side of the earth as it does for
the internet now i would be experiencing
things that are affected by the speed of
light and i might have a different model
for how the world works than the one
that we have
so
uh let's see
um
our energies is commenting um
if i always thought that if
we are like bacteria living on a bit of
sand on the bottom of an alien's shoe
while they ride an elevator what happens
when the elevator
stops yeah i mean
you know we are
but writing
in
oh for example
let's imagine
that
there was
some big
sort of tear in space time
so you know black hole has an event
horizon we don't actually know all of
the weird pathological things that can
happen in space time
so for example in our theories of
physics there are possibilities of
things i've called space tunnels which
are things where essentially you can
have a part of the universe that has a
different number of dimensions of space
and you can kind of
you can use that to
it sort of connects different parts of
the universe in a different way there
are all kinds of weird pathological
things that could happen and yes it
could be the case
that uh there
somewhere in the universe some
some sort of tear in space time happened
it'll travel towards us at the speed of
light
we're not going to know it's coming
until it hits us
and so in that sense it could be the
case that
um we
are sort of we're just riding on some
feature of the universe
and there's a much bigger feature of the
universe
that we just are completely unaware of
up to now for example um and by the way
i mean one of the things to realize is
for example in the center of a black
hole where time stops
in in our model of physics
time
is the result of this progressive
rewriting of this network of atoms of
space it's like this computational rule
that keeps on getting run whenever it
can be run and time passes because that
rule is happening and so we are
experiencing things because
our brains are being run according to
that rule so in other words we might say
a trillion trillion trillion trillion
ins runnings of that rule that
corresponds to a second of experience
time
and if those rules weren't running
our time wouldn't be running we wouldn't
experience anything so for example at
the center of black hole in our model
physics
those rewrites just stop there aren't
any more that can be done there's
nothing more time stops
and the question is what do we
experience when time stops and the
answer is we experience absolutely
nothing
because
there is no our experience
is the result of
our brains doing things and progressing
which we describe as progressing in time
but if we look at it microscopically
it's just the running of these rules
and so if those rules stop running
there is no experience
so in other words one can think of you
know you fall to the center of a black
hole and it's like oh my gosh you know
everything's over well yes everything is
over but you don't experience you don't
have this this horrible feeling oh my
gosh everything is over
there's nothing to feel because
experience has stopped
and and so you know something like that
could conceivably happen in the universe
i think it's it seems super unlikely um
but uh uh you know that's a sense in
which
we are but riding on the back of this
kind of um this whole thing that is our
universe uh with all kinds of effects
that that um we have little control over
i mean for example one thing that could
happen you know a star near us could
turn into a supernova but explode i
think that um there is an imminent
danger of that um
i don't think there are any stars near
us that are big enough to um except for
stars that we've studied quite well by
the time they're big enough that they
have the potential in a billion years or
something to turn into a supernova we
can see them now and we know we can
check that they're not turning into
supernovas i don't think that's a
high-risk kind of proposition for right
now
um
brian is asking
uh is there a maximum to how fast we can
think
uh yes
i mean in
at the level
of the universe
doing its computation
to work out the next step of the
universe
then absolutely the best we can ever do
is to we are essentially existing in
that system that is progressing that
that is sort of determining what the
next state of the universe is
we are
our brains are merely part of that so
there's no sense in which we could out
think the speed of the universe
well i i mentioned this phenomenon of
computational irregularity we could say
the universe is going through and it's
doing all these complicated computations
and we can be do clever mathematics and
jump ahead but if we're just emulating
the actual steps
which by the way we can't usually do
but uh if we were just looking at the
steps the universe goes through we can
say well could we speed up those steps
and the answer is well the universe is
doing what the universe is doing
and we are part of that universe so we
are taking the same steps the universe
takes
so in some sense there is a a sense in
which we there's no way we can outrun
you know we are part of the universe so
we can't outrun it
and
our way of measuring time it's all a bit
circular because our way of measuring
time
is based on the our experience of time
things happening and you know the thing
that determines i don't know the
transition in the cesium atom or
something which is the standard of time
these days
is determined by it's some number of
update steps
in the evolution of the universe
and so that's that's our measure of time
is based on the number of update steps
and our ability to think so to speak to
to compute in the universe is also just
based on these update steps so we can't
we can't kind of outrun that now you can
say what is the processing speed of the
universe
and what is that maximum speed
um and i don't we don't know yet because
there's a an important parameter in our
models of physics
which essentially determines the
elementary time or the elementary
lengths it determines
when
uh sort of two successive rewrites
happen in this network
what is the amount of time that we
assign
between those two updates so in the end
gazillions of those updates will do the
things that constitute what we identify
as one second of time elapsing but the
question is uh how many of those are
there that correspond to something that
we identify like this transition with
cesium atom or whatever it is that we uh
identify as being the elapsing of one
second of time
and we don't know the answer that we
don't know what that parameter is i'd
really like to know hopefully the next
few years it will be possible to do
experiments to determine that we don't
know that so we kind of think maybe it's
a
uh trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillionth
uh trillionth trillion
i'm still not doing very well counting
on my fingers another trillionth of a
second
um is the elementary time
and if you know the elementary time
you can
estimate well there's some other things
you have to estimate you you need
the intrinsic parameters of the model
are the speed of light
a thing we call the maximum entanglement
speed
and a thing we can call the maximum rule
speed
um these are these are sort of three
parameters that determine
the the structure of this model we don't
know we know the speed of light we don't
know the other two
um but
if you make some very rough estimates
um
the uh the maximum processing speed of
the universe
is
you have to measure it in terms of the
speed of doing computations so at the
speed of taking a program
and processing that program and so for
example let's imagine we have a world
from language program we can say how
many tokens are there in that piece of
language code and we process those
tokens at a certain rate per second
and so uh i had one estimate that it's a
a um 10 to the 450 in other words a one
with 450 zeros after it um
is
wolfram language tokens per second
as my rough estimate of the processing
speed of the universe
so that would be the maximum speed at
which
any computational process can happen in
the universe
now building an actual machine
that
would be where we would be able to
understand the output and so on far away
far far away from that i mean just to
talk about sort of computation and one
of the things i've been thinking about
recently is computation at a molecular
scale computations we do right now are
based on packets of you know 100 000
electrons in a silicon crystal and so on
that's how computers work right now but
the question is if you were to be able
to do a computational level of
individual molecules
what uh what could you achieve there and
and what could you do what what kind of
observations can you make when let's say
you've got these configuration molecules
so i kind of suspect that in biology
there are many
situations in which you get some
elaborate configuration molecules which
means something to the biological system
but the chemist right now just says oh
there's a certain concentration of that
chemical they're not taking account of
the sort of sub-chemistry of seeing the
actual positions of all these molecules
and you know when we have something like
a crystal we know all the molecules all
the atoms are nicely lined up but and i
was just looking actually at cell
membranes where
you have all of these proteins that are
sort of sticking through cell membranes
in what seems like kind of a random
arrangement and there's sort of a
question of how those things are um you
know what
is there in fact information
is there is there some representation is
that at a molecular scale is there sort
of is the answer written in the
configuration of molecules on the
surface of a cell for example we don't
know that yet um anyway this is
something something i've been thinking
about but this is in terms of sort of
different experiences of the world
that's a very different level of
experience if your experience is
something uh you know if your experience
is down at the level of sort of proteins
on a cell surface
in a biological cell at um at a very
microscopic scale you can end up with a
very different kind of view of physics
and so on than we have at the scale that
we're at
all right um
well we should probably wrap up here i
think i'm late for something else um
but uh
uh that was fun you guys are getting me
to do
um
a certain amount of um
somewhat real-time philosophy
and uh
uh
um this is um
uh these are kind of um we're we're
diving into pretty deep questions about
uh
sort of well i would say even life the
universe and everything in some sense
um
and uh
um
i i hope i've been able to explain this
in a way that people can follow um
it's uh i think the thing that is sort
of exciting at a meta level about these
kind of philosophical questions is a lot
of these questions have been solidly
around for 2000 years or more of people
thinking about you know how is motion
possible what is you know what is the
world made of uh what um uh in what
sense is there some you know do we have
is experience real these kinds of things
and
you know it's rather exciting to have
been able to from the point of view of
science which is a very specific kind of
way of thinking about the world we're
able to sort of build this tower that
reaches back into these questions that
really were questions of sort of
fundamental philosophy back a couple of
thousand years ago and i'm at least
having fun sort of untangling these
kinds of things and i'm i'm kind of like
um uh if only democritus back in you
know i don't know what
400 something bc you know if only he'd
had a computer and he'd understood this
idea of computation um you know what
different conclusions would have been
drawn in the very early days of sort of
pre-science as we know it today and it's
certainly a historical amusement in a
sense that there were sort of you know
at least one example sort of the
clockwork type mechanical computing
device that existed in antiquity
it's not known how common those were but
i kind of just imagine you know people
didn't yet get the idea of the sort of
abstract notion of computation um and
had they got it sort of the history of
science would have been very different
and um that would have been a a sort of
a a different way of seeing the universe
and we'd be having a quite different
discussion about sort of these are the
laws of physics as we know them and
there might be other ones that were
known to the aliens but those aliens
were the the branch not taken of the
development of human science
all right um i think uh
should wrap up here and um
uh
um
let's see we'll be
i think next friday i may not be able to
do this at least at the same time so
uh um
if uh
you can see on our website i think or on
our twitter um when we're doing these
but i'll do them
uh i have another one next wednesday
which will be about history of science
and technology and next friday at some
time i think
a continuation of
this science and technology q a
for kids and others
all right thanks for joining